93 000 overdoses in the last year this
administration is doing nothing about
the fentanyl that's being pushed into
this country they're lacing
commonly used drugs they're lacing
marijuana with with
with fentanyl
and killing people yeah i think
yeah i think we saw when you and i were
on the border talking to border agents
they are not able to focus on stopping
the drug trade into our country the
cartels know they can start running
fentanyl which is deadly as you said and
it's going to kill thousands of people
this is we know this the binding
administration knows this and yet they
continue to allow people to come across
this country in droves and continue to
allow the importation of fentanyl that
obviously is coming through china as
well
texas attorney general ken paxton
addressing the drug crisis at the
southern border on mornings with maria
last tuesday just two days later u.s
customs and border protection made a
record-breaking seizure of fentanyl and
methamphetamine more than 17 000 pounds
in a mexican citizen's truck
that's raising new concerns about what
the bite administration is doing to stop
the flow of drugs into the united states
joining us now is new york congressman
john catko the ranking republican on the
house homeland security committee uh
congressman thank you so much for
joining here i i served with you in the
united states congress uh tell us on the
border yeah kamal harris doesn't seem to
have time to deal with this the
president has never been
uh but you've spent a lot of time on
this tell us about the drugs and the the
severity of the problem that's going
down down there
yeah
good to see you again jason listen uh
before i came to congress i was a
20-year federal organized crime
prosecutor and part of that time was
spent on the border in el paso going
after cartels and one thing the cartels
know when the border is secure it's much
more difficult to get for them to get
their drugs across when it's not secure
it's it's a piece of cake form and
that's what we're seeing now but when
the president opened up the border last
year and allowed people to flow into
this country it was a boon for the
cartels they make 400 000
at least per person coming into this
country but more importantly it allows
them to create diversions by sending
maybe a hundred people in one one spot
to come across all aboard the croatia
have come off the line to deal with that
influx of immigrants i mean aliens
coming in they just want the drugs
across the other way and it's been it's
it's creating a uh a mess in the united
states all over the place over a hundred
thousand people in the last year have
died from drug overdoses uh um the vast
majority had been laced with fentanyl
and this season of fentanyl at the
border in the last year to kill every
man woman and child in the united states
seven times over
think about that and given the fact that
you seize that much i know for a fact
when you're seizing that much that much
more is getting through so it's a crisis
that this administration has created and
he's not doing anything about it
yeah those numbers are stunning you take
such a microscopic amount of fentanyl
and it will kill you that's why when you
look at 11 000 pounds you think well
that's kind of a big number but when you
understand how small a little dose will
that like you said that could kill every
american in the united states if it was
uh administered
yeah absolutely look at in my in my
district last week we had 14 overdose
deaths in uh one night uh in just
in the city of syracuse and that was i
think it was on drugs not laser
marijuana but i'm not sure not positive
i think that was a preliminary report
and i think maria was right when she
said earlier that they're not just
lacing fentanyl with heroin it's not
just a heroin addict if you're smoking
pot you could very easily succumb to
pot lace with fentanyl and that's what's
really tragic and this is a huge
byproduct and what people don't
understand in upstate europe for example
now the borders thousands of miles away
it may be a thousand miles away but
really every state and every city is a
border state and sitting now because of
what's happening with these drugs coming
into our country and the illegal aliens
coming in that that are that are
involved in criminal contact as well
well the human trafficking i i wish
people fully understood how
dramatic this actually is because the
the toll that it takes on humans and the
human trafficking that's going on i mean
look at these statistics the statistics
are absolutely stunning they're
overwhelming and nowhere close to what
we've ever dealt with in the past
congressman
yeah you're right let's let's do a
little math here
the cartels are getting uh enriched
to an extent they've never dreamed of
just by dealing drugs they control the
border you cannot cross the border
without paying them to come in and a
human trafficking standpoint four
thousand dollars is a minimum and
oftentimes much more many of these
people coming across can't afford to pay
it so they are told by their cartels
where to go and who to appear to to work
off their debt so in fact we are
strengthening the cartel's grip on drugs
and drug distribution networks in this
country by having these people come
across who have to pay off their debts
to the cartels it's crazy i i was there
at the border at midnight and people
came across and when i was in el paso i
was a prosecutor they ran from us now
they ran to us and just basically said
i'm here let me in and within the next
day i got on a plane leaving at mcallen
texas and some of those things people i
saw that night before that come across
were put on that plane with a
packet telling them where to go and what
airlines to go to and where to get off
i've never been tested have no idea if
they're if they've been
inoculated actually virtually none of
them have them with the
and we have all those issues plus we
have them coming to work
in countries all over the city for
cities all over the country it's crazy
so the president is set to close down
traffic from eight african countries but
you go to the southern border and there
is no slowing it down and no kovid are
they even doing testing let alone making
sure that people are vaccinated
yeah so think about it 1.7 million
people 1.7 million have come across the
border illegally this past year since
president biden signed his order 1.7
million
virtually none of them if any of them
have been vaccinated and they are not
being tested in the facilities because
they don't want to test them in the
facilities because then they have to
quarantine them and there's no place to
put them so they shove them out to these
other organizations whether they get uh
tested or not we don't know what we do
know like i said from my previous
example they're often put on planes
right away with american people not
knowing who they are even because they
don't have ids we have no idea if
they're really bad people or not and we
have no idea what their health status is
and they're put on plane to some all
over the country yet if you're from uh
certain enumerated countries you can't
come into the united states if you're in
mexico and get on a plane and fly into
the u.s you've got a vaccine car you can
walk across the border and not have that
what the heck are we doing jason
well there was a report earlier this
week congressman about these afghans
that were evacuated to the united states
some 80 plus thousand people but now the
report coming out of the washington
examiner is that those people were not
fully vetted as was promised by the
president himself
right you know this there's parallels
between the border and afghanistan both
both were ill-conceived ideas by this
administration without thinking out the
entire process obviously the border is
what we discussed afghanistan's the same
way they didn't think out the whole
process they didn't realize they had to
help people get out of there that helped
us but in the process he also created
this this mass of people that ran into
the airport and got on the planes many
of whom didn't help the united states we
have no idea who these people are when
you i'm a very big supporter of refugee
processes in the united states because
refugees are generally very well vetted
i know people i was a law supporter
sudan for example he sat in a refugee
camp for a year or two after he was
designated from united states so they
properly vet him and he was a kid
these people came across they ran them
through terror databases and if the name
didn't show up they were in and so my
myself and others on the homeland
security committee are doing rigorous
oversight to try and figure out where
the gaps are remote we need to do to
slow this process down they should not
step foot into this country until they
have been fully vetted and if they're
not fully vetted as is officer situation
is we've got to hold them where they are
until we make sure they're fully vetted
we have an obligation to american people
to keep them safe and we're not doing
that when we do things like this
well the president of the united states
and the secretary of homeland security
said all these people were vetted and
they haven't been all right new york
congressman john catko the ranking
member on homeland security thank you
for joining us today